boa tarde gente confessa tô nervosa aqui
como se fosse a primeira aula porque é
uma responsabilidade muito grande emoção
além de falar de um dote piraí digital
vamos lá nós quando pensamos nesse
projeto colocar piraí uma cidade em rede
tivemos de início uma compreensão de que
deveríamos trabalhar como política
pública que era uma situação do brasil
97 até hoje entendimento perdura de uma
exclusão uma exclusão digital grande que
leva à exclusão social e nós tínhamos
naquele momento então um senso de
urgência que para desenvolver políticas
em piraí para colocar o nosso município
no século 21 que vinha de uma série de
crises a gente precisava pensar em
termos de política pública e uma
característica que eu acho que é
importante no ser humano ea generosidade
e olhar para além do seu mundo e nesse
aspecto pensando também uma questão de
escala que eu acho que hoje ela se
reflete quando piraí é um modelo de
cidade digital que serve como paradigma
para outros projetos do brasil ea gente
fica feliz e honrado porque a gente
sente que esse é um robô que nós
marcamos né embora ainda de uma forma
aquém do sonho nem que a gente tem toda
hora está renovando este sonho mas
caminharmos nessa direção
então outra coisa pra mim foi
fundamental foi o diálogo o diálogo
pensamos no futuro mas com o diálogo um
diálogo com a sociedade um diálogo com a
comunidade
em todo momento o ali kamel apresentação
coloco ele a comunidade inteligente
porque nesse momento que a gente vê a
questão colocada das cidades digitais da
cidade inteligente piraí que eu tenho
uma linha do tempo colocada aí ela desde
o princípio nós tivemos como um fator
importante a questão do diálogo de
saberes
nós não chegamos eu universidade
as universidades foram parceiras também
acho que tiveram um papel importante
o professor franklin coelho também que é
o contrário o coordenador geral do
projeto quem ajudou na foi pensar junto
à cidade o projeto tínhamos naquele
momento ali uma ambiência uma uma
construção de saberes que tinha que ser
respeitada e juntos aprendemos a
dialogar com o futuro e para além dos
processos inteligentes que são
importantes que viabilizam a comunidade
inteligente mas o capital social e o
capital humano sempre foram as nossas
bandeiras
nesse aspecto eu coloquei nesses led aí
o que nós poderíamos classificar nesses
dez anos como os dez pontos nas dez
questões que são os fatores de sucesso
do projeto
eu acho que foi uma capacidade de olhar
para o futuro
o pensado projeto como política pública
a certeza que o que produz conhecimento
ea paixão o conhecimento é fator de
autoestima para o ser humano
e pra ser feliz a pessoa tem que ter
autoestima então esse caminho trilhado
por piraí o tempo todo foi um caminho de
emoção foi um caminho de acreditar de de
querer sonhar de querer realizar alguma
coisa que a gente acha que o a população
brasileira merece e precisa e que nós
nessa realidade de um município de 25
mil habitantes poderíamos juntar os
esforços e implantar um projeto a
questão do diálogo de saberes
a questão também de apoiar a
criatividade e valorizar e as
experiências criativas a questão de
superar os obstáculos quando fala em
superar obstáculos foram os marcos
legais questão de legislação questão de
correr atrás de convencimento que de não
olhar as coisas como olhar mais pelo
lado do desafio
sim o desafio de que nós tínhamos que
transpor ao invés de olhar
o lado da dificuldade as parcerias que
foram fundamentais tivemos aqui palavra
que antecederam o dia mostrar o que é um
projeto que trabalha efetivamente com
parcerias
isso daí pra qualquer fruto de sucesso
há hoje na sociedade do conhecimento da
informação não existe chance
mais do que nunca com esta velocidade de
transformação que se unirmos esforços
nós não conseguiremos realmente colocar
nosso país o nosso município porque o
país é composto de municípios e cada um
dentro da sua célula pensar nessa
transformação unindo esforços
busco recursos locais sempre priorizado
piraí desde o início priorizou a
formação priorizou a comunidade com o
sentido que eles são os verdadeiros
protagonistas nós eu sou piauiense
nem fui criada aqui depois recebi o
título mesmo achamos sentia piraí em si
mas de alguma forma não estava no dia a
dia da cidade ea gente sabia que quem
realmente abraça a causa junto conosco
são as pessoas que estão aqui temos
vários queijos que podem mostrar que
isso foi um fator de sucesso e é um
fator de sustentabilidade do projeto
a questão também de envolvimento das
deverá setores da sociedade civil ea
coragem para a mudança de paradigma
porque é inevitável essa mudança de
paradigma com um projeto dessa natureza
então buscamos isso não cidadão ativo em
conexão com o mundo
uma coisa que usamos desde o início que
a conectividade é pré direito não chega
nesse direito a conectividade é que dá o
cidadão direito à informação
e se nós tínhamos muito claro nós não
diríamos conectar colocar uma rede no
município digital pura e simplesmente
por ter a internet
nós queremos fazer daqui uma
possibilidade de uma informação
qualificada que todos os setores o de
política pública puder ter passado
aquele momento
vou usar da velocidade da vantagem da
velocidade que nos traz nos a tecnologia
da sociedade da informação e do
conhecimento da informação chegando ao
cidadão da transparência de governo
e tudo o que foi pensado no projeto foi
muito em cima quer ver a visão nossa ela
do capital humano do capital social
então é por isso eu friso que
trabalhamos muito com conceito e
trabalhamos até hoje não é
historicamente trabalhamos do capital
social do capital humano então do douro
da comunidade inteligente e como foi que
nós tínhamos clareza não sentamos e
começamos a pensar o projeto a educação
educação realmente é o carro-chefe é
porque a educação e isso até cada hora
em cada momento as vezes que a gente
está em momentos lúdicos de prazer e
você vê que isso é de domínio público
dizer que a educação é o futuro eu
coloquei uma transparência uma foto que
é da avenida do desfile das campeãs nada
da unidos da ilha do governador que dê
uma placa de ver no futuro e apontava o
futuro da educação então a gente sente
que é um um consenso de que o caminho
que temos espelhar uma educação uma
educação de qualidade uma educação que
se beneficie que a informação hoje pode
estar além das paredes de uma sala de
aula e que o papel que eu vou falar um
pouco mais adiante da sala de aula é um
papel muito mais desafiador é um papel
realmente da construção do conhecimento
então começamos o projeto ea gente usou
durante longo tempo até nas horas de
apresentações
a poesia de antónio machado grande poeta
espanhol antonio machado que diz
caminhante não é caminho o caminho esse
pai do andar então com uma ideia uma
sinergia grande com o foco porque tem
que ter o foco caminhamos né
fomos olhando para o futuro como até
hoje acho que o desafio continuamos
olhando para o futuro e passo a passo no
sentido da implantação de um projeto que
é não não é a tecnologia por si só é a
tecnologia como uma ferramenta de
inclusão
então uma das coisas de desafios
nós queremos um resumo
tá diferente mas não podemos fazer da
mesma forma se fizer da mesma forma não
tem um resultado diferente e como fazer
isso como uma reflexão e mais uma vez o
como fazer exige um olhar para o futuro
e um diálogo com a realidade
nós temos que estar com os pés no chão
nós temos q ta saímos nós por exemplo
quando penso do lado os pesquisadores
dos lados mesmo das empresas dos
diversos setores têm que vir por
território tem que vir por pisar no
território e entender qual é a realidade
tudo o que já foi construído porque
ninguém está procurando novas habilidade
estamos procurando como caminhar de
forma diferente de diante de um
conhecimento de novas linguagens que a
tecnologia e percebemos que tudo porta
para a questão da questão primordial é
todo o desenvolvimento temos o
desenvolvimento na área de saúde tivemos
ontem entre emocionante o cartão saúde
na praça sendo distribuído telessaúde
que caminhando da área de governo com a
transparência
mas a gente sente que a comunidade
precisa é da da educação tivemos a
oportunidade de ver o depoimento da da
thaisa que na hora que ela fala que ela
levou para a família ela levou pra
família porque tem uma ambiência a
cidade digital permitiu essa ambiência
ela chega em casa e dialogar com o pai e
fazia parte e faz parte de um projeto
pedagógico a inclusão da família aí como
duas coisas que dita que a gente vai ter
o prazer de ouvir gilberto gil não é que
nos marca uma é quando ele fala quem
quem não for no cordão da banda larga
não vai saber que mudou seu ea outra
quando ele esteve a equipe daí que nós
colocamos isso em 2007 que ele ser e ele
colocou aqui eu estou vendo a
responsabilização da família e é nesse
sentido que procuramos os caminhos do
que a gente chama nós educadores da
educação formal à educação está dentro
da sala de aula da educação não formal
aqui
além da escola ea educação informal que
a educação da comunidade com com
perspectivas né da quebra inclusive da
rígida estrutura de disciplinaridade
porque o mundo hoje exige um diálogo de
saberes um conhecimento interdisciplinar
de verão tem maior informação matemática
não é mas eu sei o quanto é importante
para que eu tenha sentido que o
conhecimento seja ressignificado que eu
tenho um diálogo com os meus colegas
o quanto é enriquecedor na construção do
conhecimento
na abordagem transdisciplinar quando a
gente pensa pra além das disciplinas
mais longe de pensar que os grandes
problemas
o problema da sustentabilidade do mundo
o problema de lixo na casa por questão
digital que nós abordamos loud lixo
digital
então essas grandes soluções que passa
pelo que a gente chama de trânsito e
criminalidade
então o que trabalhamos
usamos esse conceito de mobilidade que
nós temos é o pico idade que é o poder
que está o bico cidade tecnológica nós
podemos estar em qualquer momento em
qualquer lugar então isso quer ver como
o como a educação se privilegia dessa
ambiência tecnológica como é que ela se
a tecnologia por si só não vai fazer
melhor a educação mas ela potencializa a
educação para o século 21
ela cria oportunidades de bill cidadão
seja inclusive ter mais autoconfiança um
aluno no momento que a gente dá
oportunidade a ele de fazer o que foi
feito ontem numa gincana digital
a gente sabe que aquilo mexe com a
autoestima dele méxico o reconhecimento
do conhecimento dele e foi nesse caminho
que nós traçamos e caminhamos para a
expansão da escola para além da do
espaço escolar
não estamos desvalorizando a escola pelo
contrário ela tem um papel fundamental
de catalisadora elas em trair avaliou a
questão importantíssima não é o
significado da escola mesmo não está
sendo perdido ela está assumindo outras
responsabilidades ampliando os espaços
educacionais para além daquele espaço
porque a tecnologia hoje colocada no
mundo
me disse isso nos permite uma função de
vários ambientes que foram colocados
anteriormente então e mais por um lado é
isso agora eu acho que piraí marca a
diferença porque por outro lado o povo
fazer eu tenho que fazer de forma
diferente então quem é um município que
teve a coragem de repensar os seus
tempos de aprendizagem o tempo dentro da
sala de aula os projetos que
efetivamente beneficiam e as parcerias
que nos beneficiam disso temos o projeto
do aluno tutor que é um projeto em
parceria com a empresa cisco onde a
formação tecnologia que é um projeto
inclusive de gênero porque uma menina
naquela não tiver oportunidade uma
menina de de comunidade carente ela não
tiver a oportunidade do acesso à
tecnologia ela normalmente ela vai se
encaminhar para outras carreiras sem ter
o direito a esse conhecimento a
descobrir esse mundo é um projeto também
enterro da autoria é encantadora gente
vê o qual o potencial dessas crianças
sendo respeitado que a escola tem que
ser geradora de sonho ela não pode matar
os sonhos
a escola tem de encantar e isso sempre
que nos moveu e móvel município no
caminho da educação e o e sempre olhando
a inovação olhando a robótica a
possibilidade de uma programação uma
criança entendendo hoje que o mundo que
a gente fala
nós estamos precisando de pesquisadores
não estavam precisando de engenheiros
mas isso se constrói na base
não vamos pegar alunos já é quando chega
na minha sala de cálculo para formar e
falar bom daqui vai ter um grande
engenheiro eu perdi a oportunidade
então trabalhamos hoje o grande questão
hoje a sala de aula com o papel dela eu
quem fala a sala de aula invertida a
informação a informação você busca
individualmente eu enquanto professor eu
devo buscar preocupar e qualificar a
informação para o aluno em da orientação
agora o aluno a espaço da sala de aula é
um passo da reflexão é um espaço de
discussão eu não estou criando novas
habilidades com a tecnologia a
viabilidade do ser humano de pensar de
criar
refletir né de buscar novas descobertas
e isso faz parte inerente do ser humano
o que eu estou buscando são as novas
formas utilizando as novas linguagens
eu estou respeitando o direito de
conhecimento de cada aluno e estou
respeitando o que eu não posso achar que
todos que estão numa sala aprendeu mesmo
tempo da mesma forma então eu uso
tecnologia o meu favor porque se ele
busca informação fora e aí nós vamos
discutir os conceitos e eu vou ter o
direito de ouvir as dúvidas inclusive os
questionamentos em relação à própria as
colocações minhas e um diálogo de
saberes respeitando que um aluno de
repente possa me questionar e juntos
construímos um conhecimento agora um
fator importantíssimo que eu acho é a
questão que há é uma coisa pro brasil
pra piraí pronto é a questão de um
ecossistema da educação e ecossistema no
sentido mesmo do equilíbrio no sistema
todas as forças têm que se juntar todos
têm que seus parceiros e essa também é
uma mensagem que eu trago da experiência
nossa do piraí digital
nós tivemos a coragem nesse aspecto
tivemos também o prazer a alegria eo
privilégio de contar com um parceiro
sério e que sonham do mesmo ano na jeito
que nós para uma taça uma sociedade mais
feliz
então essa integração dos diversos
setores é fundamental para se construir
um projeto que realmente ps a felicidade
de uma nação a felicidade de um povo
porque nós não queremos construir
tecnologia pela tecnologia mas ela uma
olhada e nós temos que colocar a escola
a educação no século 21 como outros
setores da cidade a sociedade já
entraram e criar criar uma sociedade
entender a escola tem um papel de que d
o encantamento do conhecimento que nós
tico importante a atitude ser formada é
o desejo de se aprender e de se aprender
que a educação tem esse papel hoje que é
de buscar um encantamento de manter o
encantamento e de permitir aquelas
crianças e um adolescente que continua a
sonhar e que tenham esperança na vida
muito obrigado